[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka mid marvel cause i'm
mid hey that's what the kids say anyway
the second episode of ms marvel is now
out and throughout this video we're
gonna be breaking down the plot easter
eggs and things you missed marvel
paul just shut shut the [ __ ] up it's
it's it's early
shut up shut the [ __ ] up
okay mate sorry anyway full spoilers
ahead so if you haven't had a chance to
check it out then check out now please
hit the thumbs up button and also don't
forget to subscribe for breakdowns like
this every day without the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into ms
marvel episode 2. so after avengers con
has discovered that wasn't a pun by the
way khan has discovered her powers come
from her bangle kept calling it bangles
last week but as many of you pointed out
there is just one however this got me
thinking about what could come in the
show if they are the [ __ ] bands as we
theorize then there is likely another
one out there so in a way me saying
bangles was correct from a certain point
of view later on we actually get a hint
to a mysterious character that reaches
out to kamala and it is possible that
she has the other one now there have
been massive chain chips when it comes
to her powers but they do somewhat
reference the comics by having her hand
grow massive at one point the first time
she ever used her abilities was to save
zoe by making her hand and big in and
the character making her fists larger is
often how she fights against her enemies
they also describe the powers as being
tied to ideas further cementing this as
a sort of green lantern-esque ability
where one's imagination very much powers
the ring in the 90s they actually made a
rule when writing green lantern comics
that you couldn't use the same thing
twice and this led to lots of creative
things coming out of the ring hope this
is murdered in the show too and i
actually really enjoyed this episode
after feeling a bit meh on the last
entry now we open to feel so good by
mason puff daddy though i think the
latter is going by puff father diddy or
p diddy nowadays anyway
this actually used to be one of my
favorite songs growing up and the
opening line
is something i say all the time just a
bit of trivia there now juxtaposing last
week's entry where kamala ended the
school as somewhat of a downtrodden
loser here she's dribbling in the
hallway correcting the coach for being a
dribbling idiot and shifting people out
of the way of her locker here she bumps
into cameron who she feels some
chemistry between and this is given a
subtle nod by the chemistry book that
she ends up holding burke bumping is a
common trope in romantic comedies for
how characters meet and cameron actually
plays a big part in the comics i don't
want to spoil too much namely what the
character does but he himself ends up
getting powers too and he becomes an
inhuman in the source material we
discover that he and his family
originally lived in jersey city and that
they were close to the cons however they
moved away when he was five and ended up
living in houston texas for several
years cameron was very intelligent and
he got accepted into mit just like
spider-man's best friend flash thompson
in the show he's british which means i
get to do my my steven graham voice but
where i'm talking about the character
what do you mean that's how i talk
anyway now on the night kamala gained
her powers when the terrorism misrolled
in he too was exposed to it and it's
going to be interesting to see how
things go with his mother getting
involved though he was tied to the
inhumans in the comics it is important
to bear in mind that they have removed
this origin story from kamala so who
knows his mother may have studied the
other bangle or something along those
lines eventually kamala might even be an
inhuman already and the band could just
unlock her abilities to tap into this
and the negative zone her powers are
still a bit up in the air though and as
of now we're not really sure where they
originate from though it is likely that
we'll find out in the next episode
however we do get this important line
about the power being within her so it
looks like your power isn't coming from
the bank
it's coming from within you
last week her mother quickly hid the
item away from her after it showed up
and judging by this episode she knows
exactly what's going on with it next
kamala also drops this line about
ant-man
what makes you think you have airmen
powers because we're about charming and
we look a lot younger than we are
this is likely an in-joke to paul rudd
not really aging and blade mate you need
to investigate this day walker he's a
he's a day walker i tell you also it
should be noted that in the comics
kamala can shrink down similar to
ant-man and she does this when trying to
rescue zoe on her first night out now
since being saved by her zoe is cashing
in on all the hype and she's currently
going viral in school like samantha from
class 11d when i was young and you know
who you are you're filthy [ __ ] now this
is similar to the comics and in that she
became a star amongst the students by
featuring in several news reports his
posters up for the homecoming dance an
event that might even end up popping up
in the series and as we know it's
something that was also pivotal to the
origin story of the mcu spider-man
speaking of spider-man we also get a
possible nod tonight monkey when zoe
makes up the name night light to talk
about who saved her so who was it uh
night light
yeah night light
episode one also opened with the song
blinding lights by the weekend and we
know that hard light is what our powers
are based around they go a bit haywire
and in order to figure them out
a sports training montage
now this is of course a staple of
superhero movies and it feels very
similar to the one from shazam due to
its light tone in any sport if you want
to go from just a beginner
[Music]
this aesthetic was also seen in the
daredevil movie when a young matt
murdock trained his abilities on the
rooftops of hell's kitchen in the
background we hear the song goddess by
cruella emphasizing how kamala feels at
this point kamala ends up looking over a
mobile game not sure which one it is let
me know and this inspires her to create
floating platforms which pop up
throughout the episode these however can
also be used as weapons and she knocks
off bruno's aviators which could also
call back to captain marvel who wore the
same thing
[Music]
upon analyzing her abilities kamala asks
if she's asgardian potentially and in
agents of shield we actually found out
that many of them had lived on earth for
millennia and that they'd actually had
children most of which were unaware of
their legacy kamala also wears a green
pilot jacket during some of these
moments further calling back to her idol
carol danvers at this point bolshee and
akira head to the mosque this is pulled
directly from the first graphic novel
and the conversation they have is almost
exactly the same nakia and kamala
discuss how pristine the men's section
is and this sort of mirrors how she
views her brother as being able to do
what he wants while she was forbidden
from going to avengers con i do think
her mother is just doing this to keep
her safe though as she likely knows the
truth about kamala and her ancestry
issue thief is struck again and kamala
will no doubt get to the bottom of this
i'm guessing in a future episode and
that night she heads out to zoe's party
and i love how she's constantly getting
backers from bruno reminds me of my
school days and this party is raped
right out of the first graphic novel in
that she was given an orange in vodka
which she was told was just orange juice
some of the source material she ends up
spitting it out however they do change
up some aspects of it originally this
made her head home which is when the
territory misrolled in it was here that
she gained her powers but as she already
has them the riders don't need her to
leave cameron does a front flip into a
pool and man gets several combo points
from kamala he also has dog tags which i
used to wear as well even though i'd
lose a fight with steve rogers pre-serum
oh [ __ ] the cops and they end up heading
out in cameron's uncle's car kamala
called shotgun and even though she's
fixated on him just like a bruno he's
been there the entire time now cameron
calls bruno ryan which as we know from
screen crush is the dumbest most idiotic
name on the face of the earth shut the
[ __ ] up ryanairy they bring up the
sweatshop boys and also the bollywood
movie basically they hit it off just
like the pair did in the comics and in
issue 13 they talked about bollywood
movies with one another he gives her his
number but be careful mate might get
roman charges if you've not changed
contract and they get dropped off at
circle q which as we discussed last week
is where bruno works at in the comics
kamala returns home and dances to be my
baby by the runettes she's over the moon
and though i had my mixed opinions on
the first episode i think that iman
valani is killing it as the character
she's really captured the fun side of
kamala and spends at night texting
cameron we get another great animated
scene along with some baby slots the
name of her youtube channel which
got no subs he got no fans he got no
subs see you chump
akamala has a powers malfunction at
school which is similar to when they
went weird during issue 2. how this
happens seems to be because she's
resting her head against the bangle and
her wrist slips which then activates it
it has been said by the creative team
that she's similar to a gin or a genie
and much in the same way that you rub a
lamp to activate it this could be
mirrored in the bands as well kamala
hides away from this and as we discussed
last week with g willow wilson the show
is likely going to be about identity
this was shown in the split panel that
appears and nakia is also a character
that touches upon this motif she brings
up her hijab and discusses what it means
to her which i know a lot of people will
relate to i do think it's important for
everyone to get characters like them in
shows like this and a nice little scene
that happens between the pair bruno gets
into caltech but he doesn't really want
to go because he wants to spend the
summer with kamala he goes outside to
ask if she wants to practice her powers
but she's good at the plans with that
damn bloody cameron bloody handsome
devil from britain now he a bit like
someone i know now he lets her drive
showing that he views her as an adult
whereas her parents and brother they
don't see her on that level be careful
though mate crash the instructor's car
first time and yeah don't trust her now
her brother stands outside the shop that
they go to and cameron ends up touching
her wrist i actually think that he was
doing this on purpose to try and
investigate the bangle to see if it was
there which does sort of set up what
happens at the end that night her father
goes over their family history and he
brings up the partition he then touched
upon the british rule and this caused
numerous issues in the country this
clearly weighs over the family's head
and i do think moments like this are
important to discuss as they're often
whitewashed it also begs to question
whether cameron was changed up to be
british because of this motif but let me
know below exactly what you think now
kamala's dad brings up a miracle that
happened further hinting to the power
that exists within maniba's family
meniba's mother was just a toddler at
the time of the partition and she and
her family were meant to board the last
train but she got separated from them
she managed to make it back onto it
though saying that she followed a trail
of stars to her father and the band
lights up at this point she has evasion
of a figure likely her great-grandmother
aisha who disappeared during the
partition it seems like she might even
be trapped in the negative zone and she
is attempting to escape it she appears
later on in the entry reaching out to
her i think if she grabs her hand then
she'll finally see the truth her brother
brings up the evil eye and then kamala
facetimes her grandmother who starts the
call with the phone zoomed in up too
close to her face lots of old people do
that and she doesn't really want to talk
about it as miniva will get upset but i
do think aisha was wearing the other
band and that she got stuck in the
negative zone the next morning her
father brings a bon joey a band that
also originates from new jersey they
talk about slippery when wet they're
alba mate not that and the eid festival
is packed with bruno attending it too
kamala makes an illuminati's joke saying
they know everything and that's probably
because they have the smartest man alive
in there oh now there's several groups
at the festival including the mosque
bros the pious boys the sunday school
teachers the insta clique who we saw
taking photos in the mosquillia the
rivets mini harami girls and lastly the
illuminantes just stay away from wonder
please nakia is trying to take votes for
the board and she asks yusuf to put his
money where his mouth is for why they
moved to america now zoe being a celeb
somewhat blows up in her face as she's
interrogated by damage control
hilariously agent cleary uses the exact
same tactic that he tried on ned however
whereas he saw through the act zoe buys
into the good cop
and completely plays into his game
playing these scenes side by side it's
so funny and he ends up changing his
tune and trying to find out what she
knows this leads to them surveilling
every temple and mask and we discover
that aisha seemingly put a curse on
everything she touched there's lots of
rumors about her killing people not
liking the thumbs up button running off
with other men and just being an
all-around evil person it is possible a
negative zone ended up bleeding into the
real world though and this caused the
curses that they're talking about at
this moment a kid almost dies of suicide
by selfie and kamala steps in in her
costume this is similar to the comics in
which he help people throughout jersey
city in her disguise of captain marvel
they shout out its nightlight possibly a
nod at the moments with night monkey in
far from home she finally controls the
hard light and creates platforms to walk
on which allows her to go and save the
boy superhero landings are back baby and
this sends her viral i did slow down the
instagram names but i don't think there
was anything there that was a nod to the
comics like how they were last week
might be wrong though but i don't know
everything mate in fact i'm pretty
stretched even talking about hard light
at the moment now one of the drones from
far from home pops up and as we know
from nowhere home damage control
confiscated these from peter parker
after they arrested him cameron shows up
to save the day and it turns out that
his mother has had her eye on kamala for
a long time all the play by cameron it
was you should have stuck with bruno and
it's your own bloody fault for not
listening to your uncle kevin's spoilers
see you chump
now who she really is is difficult to
tell and this is the episode where we
all stop getting early access so i can't
pretend i didn't watch them all and then
just come out with these crazy fan
theories that are 100 right a huge shout
out to katie doyle who sent me through
an image of the back of the ms marvel
funko pop box and on it we can see aisha
najma and red dagger the latter of which
i'm guessing is cameron in the comics
red dagger is a vigilante called kareem
whose mother is kamala's auntie this
could potentially tie back to the
cousin's story from before but it's one
of those things that's still a bit of an
unknown looking at the images of najma
from what marvel has released this is
cameron's mother but there's not
actually a character that i'm aware of
in the comics that carries this name
however the word najma means star and
this could hint a star from the comic
book universe this character is a
captain marvel villain that actually
ended up stealing her powers potentially
showing what her endgame is here she
also joined the thunderbolts and as we
know from this week's announcement from
justin kroll a movie for the group is
currently in development either way i
really enjoyed this episode i think it
was much better than last week which i
was a bit mad on the series is really
fun and it's a cool high school coming
of age story i think is elevated by its
effect the likability of the characters
and what they're doing with them the
early access screeners have stopped now
so next week's video will probably be a
bit later on than this one dropped i'm
gonna post obi-wan first as it's
probably gonna be the bigger episode
with it being the penultimate one and
then i'll see if i can get this out
before the boys drops on friday anyway
i'd love to hear your thoughts on the
show so comment below and let me know we
are running competition right now and
giving away three copies of everything
everywhere all at once on the 15th of
july and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode the winners of
the batman competition are on screen
right now so that's you then message me
on twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out brighton of the boys
episode 4 which will be linked on screen
right now loving the show right now
packed with loads of callbacks to the
comics so definitely go head over there
right after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video i've been
poor i'll see you next time take care
peace